jack-jack crushing Edna's Fashion Show
the return of Carrie the babysitter and
the reveal of frozen's wife or just some
of the amazing scenes cut from Pixar's
Incredibles - yep UK movie lovers it's
Jan here and in this video I'll be
revealing and explaining five
Incredibles - deleted scenes that you
probably wish Pixar included in the
movie plus keep watching to the end for
a bonus ednan jack-jack clip where i'll
reveal two new jack-jack powers we never
saw in the film if this is your first
time here I do regular deep dives into
your favorite Pixar Disney and superhero
movies so tap the bell to keep up to
date with all my new videos I'm not
playing with you it was filthy now I
really wish this scene had been in the
movie it's a wonderful call back to that
hilarious scene in the first Incredibles
where Frozone goes searching for a super
suit after looking out the window and
seeing syndromes on the droid wreaking
havoc on the city
this time around it's honey who spots
the under minors enormous drilling
machine causing chaos and who then
hilariously and frantically tries to
find somewhere to hide Frozone suit I
think it would have been nice to see the
woman behind the voice especially as she
was such a huge hit with fans in the
first film Incredibles to director Brad
Bird have said this original scene took
too much momentum away from the under
minor action sequence at the beginning
of the movie and he felt that in the end
honey was funny as a voice is that way
everyone who watches a film can have
their own idea of what she looks like
although I can see Birds perspective up
to a point and I enjoyed Incredibles too
I can't help but think this extra scene
with honey would have been just
fantastic fun fact the design for honey
in this deleted clip was actually reused
late in the movie for one of the other
supers who assemble on the devas yacht
Edna and Jack Jack scenes together as
some of the funniest in Incredibles -
and there's some amazing bonus material
on the blu-ray which reveals some great
extra scenes with the two characters the
first is a deleted scene where Edna is
hosting her own fashion show which Jack
Jack accidentally and amusingly
interrupts I'm operating a no sleep I'm
telling you this baby is freaking me out
I don't know where he's gonna be I don't
know what he's gonna be bad anything can
happen and I've got to respond Robert
what what the baby is gone
[Applause]
[Music]
what is there Tom Frey they're going
crazy they want you to take a bow and
they want the glitter baby no glitter
baby first the team will bow then the
junior designers then I will come now
collector baby this is a great theme
that I'm sure many fans would have loved
to have seen in the final film
it shows how Edna's real passion is
designing outfits for supers but because
they're illegal she has to work with
supermodels who we know Edna has very
little regard for supermodels I think
super about them spoiled stupid little
stick figures with puffy lips looking
only about themselves
Plus seeing Jack Jack turn into a
glitter baby would have been really fun
and I wonder if it's supposed to be an
additional power we didn't see in the
movie we did see Jack Jack's mimicry
powers when he transforms his appearance
into a reflection of Edna's but this
feels like it might be a kind of
adaptive or camouflaging type power
Incredibles 2 is Pixar's longest film to
date and a suspect this scene was cut
because the movie was pretty packed well
then we do get some fantastic moments
with Edna and Jack Jack in the final
film it's always great to see more by
the way the clothes and Edna's fashion
line mode were worn by models but still
drew inspiration from the powers of
Edna's favorite clients superheroes for
example the see-through chiffon around
this models head was inspired by the
look of a force field next up is a
deleted scene that's perhaps a bit dark
while we discover what happened to
Carrie the babysitter
after the first movie hi Nancy Oh Helen
I hope we're not interrupting dinner
actually we'd like to talk to Carrie but
we thought it might be best if we just
drop by you were supposed to be back
late in the evening you left her in
charge of your baby overnight and into
the next day well I'm sorry about that
that was not planned via the kids kind
of surprised me no that took us by
surprise as well the baby's a lot of
responsibility for a teenager and I
think Carrie got a bit overwhelmed she
was hysterical she calmed down
she's been twitchy ever since Oh mr.
Mickey fire khari
just the girl i wanted to see we were
talking about when you were babysitting
for us did you notice anything odd about
Jack Jack not that I room
member it's a blank but all those phone
messages you left us phone messages you
don't remember no hope I don't was that
no wet Jack Jack that's what I'm talking
about
twitchy Carly's role in the first
Incredibles movie was expanded when she
featured in the short film Jack Jack
Attack which showed her discovering baby
Paz superpowers and then having her
memory wiped by Rick Ditka this deleted
scene from Incredibles 2 is pretty dark
because it looks like Dicker's memory
erasing might have actually really
messed Cori up korie's obviously a fan
favorite character especially since
appearing in the Jack Jack short so I
think many Pixar fans would have liked a
chance to catch up and find out what
happened to her
however the answer is a little
unsettling to say the least and given
this scene was one of the filmmakers
options for opening the movie I can see
why Pixar ended up scrapping it there's
an interesting action scene cut out of
the final movie were Edna's high-tech
systems at her home begin attacking her
a mr. incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the theme that bird wanted to explore in
this deleted scene was the idea of
artificial intelligent systems turning
against their human creators if you feel
like this sounds familiar you're right
because it's pretty much what happened
when syndromes omni droid turned against
him in the Incredibles
initially this artificial intelligence
theme was actually the main story for
the sequel in this cutscene bird wanted
to show what could happen if high-tech
systems like the ones Edna has became
corrupted this idea of corrupted AI was
eventually abandoned though in favor of
the screen slave a villain plot perhaps
because it might have felt too similar
to the omni droid twist from the first
movie this action scene which has vibes
of James Bond about it does look pretty
cool though and Berta said he might
still explore the AI idea in another
movie Incredibles 2 opens at a very fast
pace pretty much picking up with the
pars facing off against the Underminer
however originally bird planned to kick
the movie off at the par family home and
remind us how it was destroyed during
the battle with syndrome I hate to cut
short a tender moment but unless you
want to explain this to a crowd come on
when they notice I'm gone just say I
went to call dicker okay although it's a
fun clip it's not as good as the
action-packed
opening scene we did get especially as
it doesn't tie in as well with the very
end of the first movie where the under-
certainly popped up and here's the bonus
Edna and Jack Jack seen from the auntie
Edna short which shows what happened the
night after Bob left Jack Jack with Edna
Walley got some sleep okay come out and
show me kid yes there it is the room is
yours they are lucky to be in your
presence now the turn yes you are tiny
God let's show him how fabulous that
turned that Edna gets Jack Jack to do is
just adorable and when she calls him a
tiny God it's a callback to the first
movie where Edna was frustrated with not
being able to legally design for supers
anymore
hey you're stood a sign pop gods also
notice in this scene how Edna's been
making a list of all of Jack Jack's
powers the movie revealed at the end
that Jack Jack has a total of 17 powers
and so far Edna seems to have 14 of them
on her list but intriguingly there's two
new ones listed under Edna's elemental
shift category cool smoke and liquid a
promo spot for the blu-ray release shows
what these look like
it appears that Jack Jack can turn into
smoke allowing a ball that Edna tosses
at him to pass right through him then
there's a shot of Jack Jack where it
looks like he can even turn into a
literal water baby these two powers
didn't show up
Incredibles - but if you'd like a full
breakdown of all of Jack Jack's are the
seventeen powers tap here to watch my
Jack Jack powers explained video or
click the link in the video description
below now do you wish any of these
deleted scenes have been included in the
movie let me know what you think of them
in the comments below tap left to check
out all my other Incredibles - and Pixar
videos or tap rights for another video
you're sure to LIKE and if you enjoyed
this a thumbs up in a share would be
fantastic thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers